-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Alright!
Let's get to the news.
President Biden said yesterday
that he is prepared to negotiate
on his $2 trillion
infrastructure plan,
while Major absolutely is not!
"Did you just question
my master?
Guess what.
Now, it's $3 trillion!
Want to go for $4 trillion?"
Lawmakers in Arkansas --
"I haven't learned anythin
in pet school."
[ Laughter ]
That's not what they call it
They call it obedience school.
That's what I was looking for.
See? I go off cards and...
[ Laughter ]
...doesn't turn out
that well for me.
Lawmakers in Arkansas
are considering
the state's first-ever
hate crime bill,
which critics called
"hate crimes lite"
because it does not
explicitly protect people
who are targeted for their rac
or sexual orientation.
Incidentally,
"hate crimes lite"
is what this haircut is called
[ Laughter ]
That's just a woman who pose
for a stock photo once.
[ Laughter ]
And, now, here she is.
-Paid.
-Yeah, that's right, she mad
that stock photo money.
[ Laughter ]
Amid reports that he's
under federal investigatio
for sex trafficking,
a liberal
political action committee
put up a billboard
in Florida last week
which features a photo
of Congressman Matt Gaetz
with the caption...
And Gaetz is furious
that they didn't use
a better picture.
[ As Gaetz ]
Let me send you some alts!
[ Laughter ]
"Hamilton" creator
Lin-Manuel Miranda
yesterday attended
the opening of a new
Times Square
coronavirus vaccination center
and I know.
I know you think
we're going to do
a "not throwing away my shot
joke,
but that's where
you're wrong, pal.
You ready for this?
"Hamilton" creator
Lin-Manuel Miranda
yesterday attended
the opening of a new
Times Square
coronavirus vaccination center
while the rest of us are still
going to have to
wait for it.
Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
Should've gone
with the first one!
[ Laughter ]
According to new study,
women who are stressed
during pregnancy
are nearly twice as likely
to have a girl.
That story again --
2021 is going to be all girls.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida woman
was sentenced last week
to 30 days in jail
after she coughed
on another customer last yea
in a Pier 1
home furnishing store.
On the plus side,
her cell looks incredible.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
eating dinner together
as a family, without cellphones,
may help reduce obesity
because you're going to want
to get out of there
as soon as possible.
"Okay, I'm full.
Goodbye."
Yesterday marked
the first day of Ramadan.
It's that one time of the year
when conservatives say,
"You know, to be more inclusive,
maybe just say,
'Happy Holidays.'"
And, finally,
actor Sylvester Stallone
has reportedly joined
former President Trump's
private club Mar-A-Lago,
or, as they're now known,
Tango & Cashless.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Johnny Carson ]
Tango & Cashless.
You get that one, Ed?
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
Tango.
Tango & Cashless.
That was the monologue,
everybody.